if you watch the speeches if you read
the tweets if you survive the debate you
probably saw something obvious and
disqualifying like when sniffy Trump
went after Rosie O'Donnell or said we
can't defend Japan or gave his string of
answers in which he did not deny his tax
returns would show he didn't pay
anything and then he said that made him
smart and and said if he had paid them
they would have been squandered and some
people certainly 30 40 percent maybe
more saw their ideal president why huh
the answer is in something not addressed
in that debate Monday or anywhere else
in this campaign the Trump wall not that
wall the other wall there is another
wall and it may be the most under
covered slice of madness in this
ceaseless 15 months of electoral in PPP
public policy polling is one of the few
players in this entire Kafka esque saga
to have maintained some sense of humor
it will ask who you're voting for but
also do you have a higher opinion of
Donald Trump or middle seats on
airplanes middle seats win by the way 45
percent to 42 and in one poet asked
question 12 question 12 would you
support or oppose building a wall along
the Atlantic Ocean to keep Muslims from
entering the country from the Middle
East no you didn't just to loosen a tat
but yes we should look at that question
again question number 12
would you support or oppose building a
wall along the Atlantic Ocean to keep
Muslims from entering the country from
the Middle East as you know there is
only one correct answer to that question
and it is are you out of your goddamned
mind but are you out of your goddamn
mind was not one of the choices yes no
not sure and this is how those
participants identifying themselves as
Trump supporters came out on this vital
question of the other Trump wall 31%
said yes they were in favor of an
Atlantic wall to keep out the Muslims 52
said said no they were not in 17% said
they were not sure a wall to keep
Muslims from entering the country via
the Atlantic how are they how are they I
can barely say this how are they
supposedly breaching our present
Atlantic fortifications roboting in from
Syria are they swimming from the Isis
infested district of Mullen back in
Brussels straight through to Myrtle
Beach South Carolina even assuming some
spark of humanity and intelligence among
these 31% of Trump supporters which
would be their getting here from
so-called Islamic state to Cuba somehow
and then coming up from Cuba on a 1951
Chevy pickup truck repurposed into an
ocean-going vessel maybe the more you
think about this nonsense question and
the nearly one in three Trump supporters
who don't know enough about geography or
not enough about construction or not
enough about how deep the water in the
ocean might be or not enough about you
know life the less law worthy it gets
and the more it takes on a shape
resembling the entirety of Donald
Trump's campaign start with a threat
that exists only in theory since 9/11 no
act of terrorism has been conducted in
this country by people who were here
illegally add to that a non-existent
paranoid fever terrorists are streaming
into this country from every corner
multiply it all by fear and an
unthinking desire for mindless revenge
and a demagogue happy to exploit it all
so he can take over the country and you
get question 12 do you support an
Atlantic Wall to keep out them Muslims
yes
31% let me be clear
Donald Trump has not actually proposed
building a wall along the Atlantic a
wall which would have to be 2060 nine
miles long or ten times that long if you
wanted to be really safe and block off
all the rivers and lakes and other
bodies of water that connect to the
Atlantic he has not proposed destroying
every Beach in every Harbor and every
marina and every dock and every pier and
every bit of shipping at every business
and every city dependent on tourism at
beach goers he
say it the people who want to vote for
him said it wolof Miami all of Florida
Georgia the Carolinas Virginia Maryland
Delaware Pennsylvania New Jersey New
York Connecticut Rhode Island
Massachusetts New Hampshire Vermont and
Maine 2069 miles they don't like
immigrants and they don't like anybody
who's not white and they don't like
facts and they don't like things they
don't understand and they don't like
Hillary Clinton and that's why he's
still in the race he is indeed their
ideal present what we do about their
proud and defiant stupidity short of
finding these 31% who want an Atlantic
Wall to keep out surfboarding Muslims in
bikinis finding this 31% and forcing
them back to the second grade to start
all over again what we do besides that I
don't know but between now and November
aids do not count them or him out Trump
and his idiot supporters do not know the
meaning of the word beaten well actually
they don't know the meaning of a lot of
words and therein lies the problem
that's the closure I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space